Sometimes we may want to shape bursty
traffic patterns allowing for bursts to be sent
on the network, but still ensuring that the
flow does not exceed some average rate. For
this we might use what's called a token bucket. In a token bucket, Tokens arrive
in a bucket at a rate Rho, and Beta is again the capacity of the bucket.
Now, traffic may arrive an an average rate Lambda
average, and a peak rate Lambda peak. Traffic can
be sent by the regulator as long as there
are tokens in the bucket. To consider the difference
between a token bucket and a leaky bucket, consider
sending a packet of size B That's less than
beta. If, the token bucket is full. Packet is
sent, and b tokens are removed. If the bucket is
empty though, the packet must wait until b tokens drip into the bucket. If the
bucket is partially full. Well, then it depends. If the number of tokens In the
bucket exceed little b then the packet
is sent immediately, othewise we have to wait
until there are little b tokens in the bucket before we can send the packet.